Returning once again to our,
our window diagram. Now let's look at the third compartment, this is the one for
operations. Once again, there's optional visibility, using the same symbols we
had before. There's the name. There may be a return type,
if the operation returns some value. It's not shown in, in these particular
examples. Then there's a list of parameters. Just like you would have,
if you were describing some method within an object oriented language.
The parameter list includes a name of the parameter. It's type. You
may express a default value. And you may also indicate, whether the particular.
Parameter, is an input parameter, an output parameter or an in,
out parameter. In, out parameters are those in which the value can come in,
and a different value can be returned. Those kinds of param adjectives in,
out and in out are not shown in this particular example. In addition to
the parameters in the operations section, you can give some properties. Some of
those properties are expressed within the braces, like we've seen before. For
example, you can indicate that a particular operation is a query operation.
That is, it's only providing information about some existing attributes
that in, within the class. You can, there's, there's, properties to
describing concurrency. there's, there's properties describing whether or
not this particular operation is abstract, as would be
seen in an abstract method in obscuring language. And you can also show,
that a particular operation has Class Scope. That's shown by an underline on
the operation name, and what class scope means, is that it's not a operation
of particular instance, but a operation for the class as a whole.
For example, let's say you wanted to know how many instances of vehicles,
you had already instantiated. You can't query any particular instance and
ask it about other instances. Instead you query the class, using
a Class Scoped operation, and the class
if you've implemented things correctly can provide the answer back to you.